Explain it again.
My friend was just
trying to get me a tampon.
Your stories are
inconsistent.
So we wake up in Wantagh,
New Jersey.
Abbi's puking on
the side of the road.
No cabs anywhere.
This is our second date,
mind you.
She wouldn't call it
a date, but, uh...
(laughing)
We scheme.
We do scheme.
Your partner hasn't
mentioned a tampon once.
Sir, your guess
is as good as mine.
(Israeli soldier)
You're on Birthmarc,
yet your friend sang a Christian
song to create a diversion.
Is she even Jewish?
Honestly, your guess
is as good as mine.
Why did you move seats
to sit next to a dead man?
That's suspicious.
What?
No, no.
He-- He was sleeping.
You--
Oh, my God.
The dead guy?
Yeah, fully dead.
Nobody wanted the seats
and we had to sit next to each
other, obviously, so...
Yeah, it didn't
bother me at all.
You said your bag
was the bomb.
It is,
my bag is the bom--
Okay, Google "Refinery 29,"
in quotes, "Drew Barrymore,"
in quotes.
It's a life-changing bag,
You were asking passengers
for very strange instruments.
Twine,
someone's shoelaces,
heavy duty scissors.
To make a tampon.
What, do you think I was
making a (bleep) bomb?
Yeah!
You're here for suspicion
of terrorist activity.
Terrorism? I thought this was
about the weed in my pussy.
What?